but whatever is hunting me is far worse
than the time race
you can sense the speedforce
it's trying to kill me
hey youtubers is Charlie black flash
hype we got to talk about legends of
tomorrow there are a lot of you that
said you were having trouble finding the
show - depending on the country that you
live in
be sure to check online for where to
watch legends of tomorrow so that we can
talk about it every week and remember
it's on Tuesday nights now in the United
States so you should be able to find it
relatively quickly but new flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment about
the episode on the video if we got a
whole bunch of reverse flash black flash
flash family speed for stuff to talk
about I know they twisted everyone's
head around a little with explaining how
you bards aunt had survived from the
flash season one finale when Eddie
killed himself but Eddie's coming back
on the flash so we'll try to explain
everything so let's do it it's a little
bit different than a normal top ten
video just because black flash was such
a big deal in this episode there was a
lot of stuff going on but he was really
like the go-to thing that everybody was
asking about he was a character that was
introduced during the Wally West run
before Barry Allen came back by Grant
Morrison and Mark Millar they had like a
very short run on the flash where they
basically turned Wally
into this god of speeds it is this crazy
story line with him so when you hear
stories about Wally being able to do all
these crazy things like travel to the
edge of the universe and back in an
instant travel faster than teleporting
that came during their run which is kind
of lost in the continuity because then
geoff johns came on the title and he
sort of rewrote how the black flash
works Mary Allen became the black flash
for a brief period during rebirth when
the reverse-flash poisoned him with the
negative Speed Force sort of reversed
his polarity remember the Speed Force
obeys certain electrical properties so
there's a positive electron charge
there's a negative electron charge so
there is such a thing as the negative
Speed Force the TV show just hasn't
gotten into that yet but during their
really brief run Grant Morrison and Mark
Boal are introduced his character to
challenge Wally West where he basically
learned to outrun death he was running
from his own death is this really weird
metaphysical idea that Geoff Johns
turned into more of a practical thing
like the black flash is an actual
physical entity that will kill you
he catches up to you anything that he
touches so you can't let him touch you
there's a villain on the flash next week
that's giving them an important lesson
for how to fight that so I did a trailer
video for that I'll add a link at the
end of this the TV show version of the
black flash is pretty close to the
comics but if you remember during the
flash season 2 finale the time rapes
came in changed zoom into the black
flash so now anything that was left of
hunter zolomon is completely gone he is
fully black flash now he might not even
remember if you called him out by name
but they might address that when he goes
in the flash TV show he can smell the
Speed Force he's just as fast if not
faster than the reverse-flash who's one
of the fastest speedsters that we know
about and he's sort of a supercharged
version of the time race something much
much worse
the reason they brought him back to
legends of tomorrow first before
bringing him back to the flash is all
because of you bars Dawn's story they
explained during season two Howey bars
dawn survives he was protected by the
Speed Force when he was travelling back
to find out where Barry Allen lived in
time he had been the enemy of the flash
but he didn't know where Barry Allen
came from so they surmised that the
Speed Force protected him when Eddie
Thawne killed himself killing the wells
version of eobard thawne cut the season
3 Barry's created flashpoint his time
traveled many times gone up against the
time race and a lot of people are like
wait a minute how come the reverse flash
can time travel this much without
getting into trouble with the time race
so this is the explainer one he knows
what's coming for him
so he knows how to stay one step ahead
but to the way they explained it
retroactively Lee is that he's been
running this whole time he hasn't been
getting away scot-free it is that we
haven't seen those moments so it has
this whole effect of leveling the
playing field within the Legion of Doom
because why would a speedster need the
help of two former members of the League
of Assassins I totally love the way they
came together in this episode they just
kept making fun of each other you're
dead in the future you only have one
hand where two members who used to be
part of the League of Assassins even
though I'm the only one that got to be a
race but it just proves how awesome the
villains are this
season so this is why I am hoping so
much that they get the Spear of Destiny
and eobard thawne as he explains his
plan fixes the fact that he's a time
aberration so he will continue to exist
in the flash arrow universe in what that
might mean is that he'll end up bringing
Eddie back to life but the beauty of the
spear is a MacGuffin they sort of made
fun of that in the last episode the
spear doesn't matter it's just to make
up and it's just an object that
everybody's going for so the really
awesome things for the writers is is it
because it's so powerful they don't have
to explain everything that it can do so
they can bring Eddie back using the
spear they can just have a Oh Bart's on
fixed times so that he can continue to
exist and then the other thing is using
it to get rid of Barry Allen without
getting rid of the Speed Force in
general so there's still a couple really
big concepts from the comics that the TV
shows haven't fully explained like the
true nature of the Speed Force because
in a couple different versions of the
comic book Barry has had different
relationships there's a version of the
comics that geoff johns wrote before
flashpoint where he creates the Speed
Force himself he's sort of like a
battery so when Barry Allen dies the
Speed Force goes away but then there are
other versions of the comics where the
Speed Force is just always been there so
there's still lots of questions that the
TV shows will explain the future seasons
so the whole idea is that the villains
themselves are time aberrations they're
going to use the spear to fix that but
it also mirrors what's going on with the
heroes storylines the legend so I love
all their scenes but Martin Stein's
daughter was amazing the actors the
Placer is great I hope he comes back a
bunch more and it sounds like what's
going to happen is is that they'll come
to the conclusion did some changes to
the timeline are okay some time
aberrations are fine they don't have to
be absolutely strict about it logically
leaving the door open for a board Thawne
to fix his situation so that he doesn't
have to go away forever because the
reverse-flash is the greatest enemy of
the flesh you can't get rid of him
villains like that never die but there's
always some big twist as to how they get
defeated and are able to slink away to
fight another day so this sounds like
what it's going to be
heroes make some mistakes themselves and
decide that hey you know this is okay my
daughter deserves to exist so logically
you can understand how eobard thawne
will be able to fix his time aberration
because under the normal rule the time
masters would go after him and erase his
aberration so he would cease to exist so
this leaves a lot of questions about
what's going to happen with the Legion
of Doom in season two because they as a
group work so well together so I'm
really hoping that at least some of them
come back I really want the
reverse-flash to come back John
Barrowman zou is fantastic in all his
scenes neal mcdonough as damian darhk--
is so much more fun on this show than he
was on arrow he even made fun of arrow
season 4 2016 wasn't my best year I aim
to change that he was basically taking a
big dig at that whole season so really
like the only plot hole I saw was that
Barry had not fully explained
eobard thawne to all the people like
they didn't know who he was till martin
stein piped up but overall it was a
great episode some of you said that you
liked it even more than you liked the
flash if it seems like the legends plot
is moving a lot faster it's because they
have fewer episodes I think I said in
the last Legends video that I posted
they only have 17 episodes this season
that might get up for season 3 they've
already been renewed for season 3 but
they haven't confirmed who's coming back
and what the storyline is going to be
there's a whole bunch of stuff we won't
find out - the season finale usually
they tease what's going to be happening
in the first episode of the next season
the rip hunter twist at the end is just
them basically turning him evil by
editing his memories so that's why he
looks like he's assassinating General
Washington before he becomes president
of the United States so it's going to be
a lot of fun I totally love that they're
letting Arthur Darvill be so different
in all these different episodes the
other big thing they teased is coming up
is a Captain Cold is coming back to the
show they didn't say which episode but
relatively quickly in the black flash as
I've said is going to go get star on the
flash relatively soon as well but they
didn't say exactly which episode what's
happening later tonight is that arrow is
selecting its new Black Canary they
teased her at the end of the last
episode so be sure to check that out it
should be pretty interesting the way
they explained her character and how she
to fit into the team she's a metahuman
Black Canary so it's getting way more
comic-book II and just because everybody
seems kind of burned out on DC movie
videos I'll be doing some new Marvel
movie stuff as well as Game of Thrones
and Star Wars tomorrow so whole bunch of
awesome stuff coming in the next couple
days but congratulations to the new
flash ring giveaway winner Griffin
Karimloo please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video so I'll
announce the winner when I post that
arrow video later tonight while you wait
for that click here for the flash
episode and click here for the flash
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's I thought I'll see you
in the next video
you